[Music]
give me
Wow you are seriously loyal PCI where
yeah you know loyalty okay we haven't
officially met
cool welcome back everyone it's Charlie
this is gonna be my new Avengers
infinity saga deleted scene video for
Ironman becoming Doctor Strange Doctor
Strange becoming Ironman and then Thor
versus Doctor Strange there's a whole
bunch of really cool Easter eggs in this
so we'll break it all down if you're new
to the channel we're still doing that
giant infinity saga box set giveaway of
all the blu-rays that's where these
deleted scenes came from so all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave all your theories on the video
about Doctor Strange too so we'll start
with the Iron Man Doctor Strange scene
just because I think that's a little bit
cooler then I'll talk about the Thor
scene so during the Iron Man Doctor
Strange scene what happened was is the
Iron Man and spider-man bored
evany Maas ship during Avengers infinity
war to save Doctor Strange the needles
evany Maul was using to torture dr.
strange were gonna be way more hardcore
and he would have been in way more pain
in the theatrical cut spider-man makes a
reference to James Cameron's aliens
asking Ironman if he remembers the
ending of that movie where Ripley
battles the Queen into the airlock then
blasts her out into the vacuum of space
Ironman jokes with ebony mod that even
though he has crazy telekinetic powers
and magic off the charts the kid
spider-man has seen way more movies they
blast a hole in the hole venting ebony
maw out into space completing the joke
in the deleted version of this scene and
it's probably one of the coolest deleted
scenes from the Infinity Saga that
hasn't made it onto the blu-rays yet dr.
strangers cloak of levitation joins Iron
Man and spider-man in their attempt to
save Doctor Strange but instead of Iron
Man just confronting evany maw head-on
like he does during the theatrical cut
he pulls in Iron Man 3 scene callback to
the time he saved Pepper Potts by
sending his Iron Man armor to cover her
during that big explosion
only this time during Avengers infinity
war he's since upgraded to his nano
armor so he sends his nano armor to
cover dr. strange protecting him from
the needles so that's what it looks like
here thus this is what Doctor Strange
looks like in the full Iron Man armor
suit really cool side detail too when
he's wearing the Iron Man armor he's
called the iron mage
notice how the nano armor forms around
the eye of agamotto he was a visual
callback to the way the armor always
forms around Iron Man's arc reactors
inside note there was actually another
new deleted scene from way earlier in
the timeline during Iron Man 2 where
Iron Man pulls the same move like this
putting his nano armor on Pepper Potts
so it just goes to show you that Iron
Man had nano armor as early as Iron Man
2 it doesn't mean anything you know it
means something I don't want to play
with your ball
so while Iron Man is saving dr. strange
he leaves himself vulnerable because he
doesn't have his nano armor anymore so
Doctor Strange his cloak of levitation
seeing that Iron Man has done amiss
solid picks up the slack and covered
Iron Man helping him a levitating and
protecting him while they dealt with
ebony maw until iron man could get his
nano armor back we know that they filmed
this scene because we have
behind-the-scenes footage of Robert
Downey jr. that they released when they
were promoting Avengers infinity war
this promo footage is from way before
infinity war ever came out in theaters
so we know that they actually intended
at one point to put this in the movie in
a lot of you longtime Marvel comic book
fans will remember that Iron Man has
become the sorcerer supreme in the
Marvel Universe a couple times in the
past there was a what-if story a long
time ago where he goes to the ancient
one to cure his quote-unquote demon in a
bottle all of his problems and combines
his science in tech with his newly
learned magical abilities to become
something more akin to a Doctor Doom
version of Doctor Strange one of the
really cool things about Doctor Doom is
that he's one of the few people in
Marvel Comics that is both a man of
science and magic there aren't that many
of them so that's why he's so useful in
big stories you could put him in an Iron
Man story you could put him in a dr.
strange story more recently during the
Marvel legacy comic book series we saw a
distant future version of Iron Man that
had become enlightened enough to take
the mantle of sorcerer supreme from
Doctor Strange but that sort of an
alternate future that may or may not
come to pass my early guesses they got
rid of this Avengers infinity saga scene
because they wanted to keep the movie
shorter and save the Iron Man Doctor
Strange twist for a more multiverse
movie down the road
think Avengers secret wars are even
possibly dr. strange to multiverse of
madness ages the Kevin Feige revealed
that we would be seeing alternate
versions of characters that we already
know during dr. strange to multiverse of
madness which just implies that they'll
be viewing the multiverse so you get
brief flashes of alternate versions of
the characters right because it has to
be the alternate version of Loki that
has never met dr. strange hopefully
they'll do something brief with that
during Thor for love and thunder so it's
sort of them tipping their hand to the
big twist that they used during Avengers
infinity war where Doctor Strange uses
the time stone to see the millions of
alternate futures looking for one where
they can beat Thanos except when he's
reading Thor's future he's not using the
time stone as we can see but none of the
special effects were added during this